hey what's up it's Kelsea Ballerini and
you're watching certified country with
Sophie shoelaces
[Music]
hey there welcome back to certified
country I'm Sylvia Lacey here in
Knoxville Tennessee hometown of Kelsea
Ballerini and today she is introducing
me to a childhood favorite and it is
very delicious
tell me the story about these thumbprint
cookies okay so we're at readeth bakery
and muhammd a little and this is where
we got cookies for Girl Scout meetings
for youth group for school like it was
the B place and if you brought Rita's
cookies like you were the one and we
you're gonna need 17 oh okay
stop it melts on your mouth looks like
butter this is amazing
that's also calorie free sugar free
obviously yeah oh my god how many of
these do you usually eat in a sitting I
try and limit myself my self-control
lately is pretty non-existent really
probably a few aren't you like sweating
for the wedding no dude I probably
should be so you're performing tonight
at your high school yeah tell me a
little bit about your first performance
at your high school I did one talent
show and I sang a song called flawless
wait give me a little taste of flawless
I can't even remember I chose like um
front row in a black dress and the floor
and then um first senior concert my
choral director let me sing us on but I
recalled learn how to fly are you gonna
cry tonight holy I give it I literally
give it like maybe four songs before I'm
like change of subject or come on
geez all right here we go I'll join you
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me about high school counseling in
a few words Oh God um super awkward I
was kind of like the floater like I had
friends like in every situation but I
was never in like a full group so that
makes sense okay so like I had like a
few cheerleader friends and a few like
really into school friends and then if
you acquire a friend you know it's kinda
like a floater well you have any special
guests tonight at the show we're gonna
be here my dad will be here my best
friends from Nashville drove in I mean
it's just gonna be like full of just
like my people how much time has Morgan
spent in Knoxville with you hmm he's
been up here a lot actually yeah hmm and
he drove us here by himself to ask my
dad permission he did not he did so he
spent some time up here yeah so what is
Morgan think of Knoxville he likes it he
says that I was turned back into a
little girl when I get here
what do you mean I don't know I feel
like I just get to like breathe and like
wear my foot fan now being home
especially just a few weeks before your
wedding does it make you kind of think
about the future about what's to come
for you and Morgan and your family you
know I think it's important just going
into this next chapter of life when the
new record and and with getting married
and all that I just to be really
involved in like roots for both me and
him and really investing in our friends
and our family and in our
and as we continue to grow together and
separately like just making sure that
those are stronger so I saw pictures of
your bridal shower Tony was that amazing
yeah I mean they made it so cute it was
like Pinterest okay good
are like the most like creative people
ever I saw your big sis Hilary Scott was
there yeah what kind of advice has she
given you for this next season of your
life you know she hasn't even had to
give me any because Ric is their drummer
Lydia is from with her husband mm-hmm
and they are just the sweetest couple
and they have Eisley on the road and
they're such a team they lead by example
and I told them that I'm like I feel
like the best thing that could have
happened before I got get married is to
watch you guys all summer
[Music]
so I want to give you this to hold in
your hands it's so exciting I was like I
was so crazy about even like the back
cover like the inside booklet like I
wanted to make everything perfect
tell me about using that cover shot okay
so I think whether you're listening to a
sad song or a happy song that cover
makes sense
totally you don't a man I feel like
unapologetically like what it means to
me is when you lead with your heart and
you follow it and you commit to it you
know you don't get swayed by outside
perspectives or opinions you just follow
it and for me that's what this whole
record is it's literally it's the story
of my life the last three years and it's
just the open vulnerable truth of it you
know I know Morgan recorded vocals on
that song what was his reaction the
first time here at that song I well I
wrote it like three weeks after we met
and I was like this feels aggressively
quick why I didn't show it to him till
probably a couple months later but he
loved it
it was it was one of my favorites from
the very beginning when I showed it to
him it was one of his favorites too now
we have to talk about high school
obviously yeah
Oh
[Music]
I wrote that song when my first album
went to mastering so that's three years
old
I think full circling that song at the
high school with everything what advice
would you give to high school Kelsie
today I would say that everything makes
sense when it needs to make sense and
just breathe and know that it's all
gonna make sense one day yeah I think
the next time I see you you'll be
married already it's crazy how do you
think your life is gonna change after
the wedding I don't I think that's the
best part
yeah you know I think that we're both so
happy in our lives right now and we're
both in like the craziest season of our
careers and I think that it's just like
an extra layer of like we're gonna do
this together forever you know
[Music]
thank you so much for watching I really
hope you enjoyed this week's episode I
always have so much fun getting together
with Kelsey fun fact about that
performance fans from 28 states were in
attendance as part of Tennessee tourism
snapchat concert series called the
soundtrack of America made in Tennessee
tickets were completely free and they
were snapped up in just one minute and
that is almost all for this week's
episode of certified country except for
this we are giving away a country gift
basket chock full of clothes beauty
products and other accessories go to ET
online calm for rules and entry you must
be 18 and over to enter and to write
November 7th for your chance to win good
luck and I will see y'all again next
Friday